S
WITH JANICE DEAN, NEW YORK
CONGRESSWOMAN ELISE STEFANIK BUT
FIRST, WHILE THE JOURNALIST AT
FAKE NEWS CNN, MS IN D.C., THEY
OBSESS OVER THE FREEDOM THAT
EXISTS IN STATES LIKE FLORIDA
AND TEXAS, THERE MAY OR JUST
ANNOUNCED A CITYWIDE VACCINE
PAST COURT MANDATE.
THESE ARE THE NEW RULES.
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO DINE INDOORS
OR GO TO A GYM OR DO PRETTY MUCH
ANYTHING INSIDE, YOU WILL NEED
TO PRESENT DOCUMENTS PROVING
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN VACCINATED.
REMEMBER, FOR MONTHS DEMOCRATS
INSISTED THAT ALL FORMS OF VOTER
I.D., YEAH, THEY ARE RACIST.
THEY CALL VOTER VERIFICATION,
VOTER I.D. LAWS JIM CROW OF THE
21ST CENTURY, JIM CROW 2.0.
BUT APPARENTLY IDENTIFICATION,
DEMOCRATIC APPROVED.
JUST LIKE ATTENDING THE DNC,
WANT TO SEE YOUR CONGRESSWOMAN
OR SENATOR FROM YOUR STATE OR
GETTING A BOTTLE OF WINE OR A
SIX-PACK OF BEER, YOU NEED PHOTO
I.D. AND NOW THEY WANT YOU TO
HAVE IDENTIFICATION TO PROVE
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN VACCINATED
JUST TO ENTER A RESTAURANT, BUT
NOT TO VOTE.
TODAY BIDEN PRAISED HIS EFFORTS.
SOMETHING TO KEEP IN MIND, THERE
IS A NEW YORK STATISTIC THAT
SHOWS ONLY 33% OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN
NEW YORK CITY ARE VACCINATED, A
LOW RATE.
THIS MEANS THAT UNDER COMRADE
de BLASIO'S RULES, THAT WOULD
MEAN 66%, TWO-THIRDS OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS WOULD BE
BARRED FROM RESTAURANTS, FROM
CONCERTS, FROM VENUES WHERE YOU
HAVE BALL GAMES, FROM GYMS,
MOVIE THEATERS, ALL IN
NEW YORK CITY.
THIS WILL NEGATIVELY AND QUITE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
MINORITIES IN NEW YORK CITY AND
BY THE WAY, WHAT ABOUT MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS?
IN OTHER WORDS MAY BE YOUR
DOCTOR SAYS YOU SHOULDN'T GET
THE SHOT, SHOULDN'T GET THE
VACCINE BECAUSE OF THIS RARE
CONDITION OR THAT RARE
CONDITION.
WHAT ABOUT THE CLEVELAND CLINIC
AND FINDING THEIR SCIENCE?
HIGHLY RESPECTED MEDICAL
INSTITUTION, THEY SAID IF YOU
HAVE COVID YOU DON'T NEED ANY
VACCINE.
NEVER MIND YOUR DOCTOR-PATIENT
CONFIDENTIALITY.
ANYONE WHO IS VACCINATED IS
ALLOWED TO ATTEND INDOOR
ACTIVITIES.
THEY WILL NOW SOON HAVE TO SHARE
THEIR PERSONAL MEDICAL DOCUMENTS
WITH EMPLOYEES AT EVERY
RESTAURANT, EVERY BAR, SPORTING
EVENT, EVERY CONCERT AND OTHER
RANDOM STRANGERS ALL ACROSS
NEW YORK CITY AND THE VACCINE
PASSPORTS IN NEW YORK IS JUST
ONE OF THE DRACONIAN MEASURES
THAT ARE NOW BEING IMPLEMENTED
NATIONWIDE.
NOW IN EFFECT FOR GOVERNMENT
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
IN THE SANCTUARY CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO, WASHINGTON, D.C.,
AND DOZENS OF OTHER CITIES.
A MASK MANDATE FOR THE MILITARY
HAS ALSO BEEN REINSTATED.
CONSIDERING MANDATORY
VACCINATIONS FOR THE MILITARY.
FEDERAL OFFICIALS ALSO CALLING
ON CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS THREE
YEARS OLD TO WEAR MASKS AT ALL
TIMES IN SCHOOL.
THAT MIGHT BE TASK IMPOSSIBLE.
COLORADO, THEY ARE NOW ORDERING
CHILDREN TO STAY 6 FEET APART
FROM ONE ANOTHER AND PRACTICE
SOCIAL DISTANCING AT ALL TIMES.
THERE ARE ALSO NEW VACCINE
MANDATES AND TESTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL FEDERAL
CONTRACTORS AND GET THIS, ON CNN
FAKE NEWS TODAY, THE NIH
DIRECTOR ACTUALLY INSTRUCTED
PARENTS, YOU BETTER BE WEARING
MASKS AROUND YOUR CHILDREN IN
YOUR HOME, TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE FOR
KIDS UNDER 12, THAT THEY AVOID
BEING IN PLACES WHERE THEY MIGHT
BE INFECTED, WHICH MEANS
RECOMMENDATIONS OF MASK WEARING
IN SCHOOLS AND AT HOME.
PARENTS OF UNVACCINATED KIDS
SHOULD BE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THIS
AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
WEAR MASKS THERE AS WELL.
I KNOW THAT'S UNCOMFORTABLE, I
KNOW THAT SEEMS WEIRD BUT IT IS
THE BEST WAY TO PROTECT YOUR
KIDS.
>> Sean: THE NIH DIRECTOR DID
TRY LATER TO BACKTRACK AFTER
THAT INTERVIEW BECAUSE OF THE
BACKLASH, BUT WHO KNOWS WHAT HE
REALLY BELIEVES AT THIS POINT?
SO-CALLED EXPERTS, THEY SEEM TO
HAVE DIFFERENT MESSAGES ON MASKS
AND TREATMENTS AND VACCINES
EVERY DAY, A NEW PROTOCOL.
HOW IS THAT NOT CONFUSING?
AND THEY ARE ASKING WHERE
VACCINE HESITANCY COMES FROM?
THAT WOULD BE FROM THEM,
JOE BIDEN ON DOWN AND
COORDINATING TO THE
CONTRADICTORY STATEMENTS FROM
BIDEN, LOCKDOWNS MAY OR MAY NOT
BE COMING BACK HERE TO REMEMBER
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO, WHEN
BIDEN, FAUCI AND EVERYONE ELSE
IN THE GOVERNMENT, THEY WERE
PROMISING ALL OF US, THEY WERE
PROMISING YOU YOUR LIFE WOULD
RETURN TO NORMAL IF YOU GOT THE
VACCINE, THAT THEY, NOT HAVING
GONE TO MEDICAL SCHOOL OR
INTERNSHIP OR EVER PRACTICED
MEDICINE, THAT THEY ARE TELLING
EVERYBODY TO GET IT WITHOUT ANY
KNOWLEDGE OF ANYBODY'S OWN
MEDICAL HISTORY OR CURRENT
MEDICAL CONDITION.
WERE THEY JUST LYING OR NAIVE?
YOU DECIDE.
>> IF WE CAN GET THE
OVERWHELMING PORTION OF THE
POPULATION VACCINATED BY, LET'S
SAY, THE END OF THE SECOND, THE
BEGINNING OF THE THIRD QUARTER,
BY THE TIME WE GET INTO MID FALL
OF 2021, WE CAN BE APPROACHING
SOME LEVEL OF NORMALITY.
>> WHAT DOES 70% MEAN?
IT MEANS WE CAN NOW RETURN TO
LIFE AS WE KNOW IT.
>> THE BIGGEST TAKEAWAY IS THAT
VACCINATION IS OUR TICKET BACK
TO NORMAL.
>> WE NEED TO INOCULATE THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY BUT SUFFICE IT TO
SAY WE ARE WELL ON OUR WAY TO
BRING IN THE COUNTRY OUT OF
CHAOS, OUT OF CRISIS AND BACK TO
NORMAL.
>> VACCINES ARE ABOUT SAVING
YOUR LIFE BUT ALSO THE LIVES OF
THE PEOPLE AROUND YOU.
BUT THEY ARE ALSO ABOUT HELPING
US GET CLOSER TO NORMAL ON OUR
LIVING, MORE NORMAL LIVING.
>> Sean: NOW, NEVER MIND.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO WERE EAGER
TO LOCK US ALL DOWN AT THE TOP
OF THE HAT, IT WENT FROM BACKS
OR MASK TO FACTS AND MASK
, TO VACCINE PASSPORTS, TO
MANDATORY VACCINATIONS, WITH SOL
DISTANCING AND MOM AND DAD
WEARING MASKS AT HOME.
BUT THERE IS A BIG EXCEPTION
HERE, ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE NOW
POURING ACROSS INTO THIS COUNTRY
IN RECORD NUMBERS, THE HIGHEST
NUMBERS IN 25 YEARS, NOBODY IS
BEING TESTED, NO VACCINATIONS
ARE BEING GIVEN OUT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PRETTY MUCH
DISPERSING ALL THESE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
NONE TESTED, MOST UNVACCINATED
AND SOME WITHOUT SO MUCH AS EVEN
AN EXAMINATION, NEVER MIND A
COVID TEST.
ACCORDING TO
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT,
RON DeSANTIS, ARE ACTUALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SPIKE IN
COVID CASES.
HE'S BLAMING THEM LIKE HE BLAMES
TRUMP FOR THE IMMIGRATION
CRISIS.
THAT IS A JOKE BECAUSE THEY ARE
REFUSING TO ENACT HEALTH
RESTRICTIONS IN THEIR STATE.
THOSE STATES HAVE DONE
PHENOMENALLY WELL WITHOUT
DRACONIAN SHUTDOWNS AND OF
COURSE, BIDEN'S POLL NUMBERS,
THEY ARE NOW TANKING.
A MAJORITY OF AMERICANS DO NOT
EVEN THINK THAT JOE BIDEN IS
REALLY IN CHARGE.
THAT SPEAKS VOLUMES CONSIDERING
THE REST OF THE MEDIA MOB, THEY
ARE NEVER GOING TO SHOW YOU THE
COGNITIVE MESS THAT JOE BIDEN
REALLY IS LIKE WE DO BUT WHOEVER
IS RUNNING THE SHOW OVER THERE,
WHETHER IT IS THE FAILED BORDER
CZAR OR KAMALA HARRIS, WHO
KNOWS, MAYBE BARACK OBAMA, I
DON'T KNOW, OR THE CDC OR THE
TEACHERS UNION THAT RIGHTS
POLICY FOR THE CDC, THIS COUNTRY
IS HEADED INTO WHAT IS A VERY,
VERY SCARY DIRECTION AS BIDEN